ماذا يجب ان اكل اليوم شطيره برجر لوح
مكسرات حلويات فواكه مجففه بيتزا او لبن
قد تبدو بعض هذه الماكولات اكثر ملائمه
للصحه من سواها ولكن لديها جميعها مكون
مشترك وهو السكر احد اسباب صعوبه اتباع
حميه غذائيه هو البيئه التي تحيطنا والتي
تعتمد على هذه الانواع من الاطعمه لقد
اظهرت الابحاث انه بامكاننا الادمان على
بعض منها وعندما نعطي فئران المختبر
انواعا مختلفه من الاطعمه اللذيذه تظهر
تغييرات في الدماغ تشبه ما نراه عند
المدمنين على المخدرات مثل النيكوتين او
الكوكاين او المورفين وما هو الشيء الذي
يدمن عليه الشخص انها الاطعمه الغنيه
بالسكريات عندما تناولت حيوانات المختبر
لدينا الكثير من السكر ظهرت تغييرات في
انظمه المتعه لديها نحن مخلوقات نتطور
وفقا لعامل التعزيز ولولا وجود اشياء
نستمتع بها لما وجدنا هنا انها وسيله
تجعلنا نعيد تكرار
سلوكنا
ما اريدك ان تفعله هو تنظيم هذه الاطعمه
وفقا لما تعتقد انها نسب السكريات فيها من
الاكثر الى
[موسيقى]
الاقل
حسنا هذا بالطبع خطا عندما تاخذ التوت
البري وتجففه فانك تركز كميات السكر فيه
الى قطع صغيره اما مياه والفيتامين فيضاف
اليها الكثير من السكر ووم بال من السعرات
الحراريه تاتي من
[موسيقى]
السكر